24 ساعه مرت وما زال الرفض والغضب قائمين
مواجهه بين محتاجين من الجليه الكرديه
وقوى الامن سعيه الى عدم اتساع رقعتها
محور الجدل في التوصيل على الرغم من تاكيد
السلطات اعتراف المتهم بدوافعه العنصريه
فانها لا تخرج ما حدث فعلا عن دائره الفعل
الجنائي العنصري حتى الان
في تفاصيل طلب منظمين مظاهرات باريس من
المتظاهرين في ساحه الجمهوريه المغادره
واعتبر وان المواجهات الجاريه مع الامن
الفرنسي لا تمثلهم
الدعوه جاءت بعد مواجهات بين الشرطه
ومحتاجين من الجليه الكرديه على مقتل
ثلاثه افراد في الهجوم الذي استهدف المركز
الثقافيه الكردي وسط العاصمه باريس يوم
امس
واكد المتظاهرون ان الهجوم ارهابي وان
دوافعه سياسيه
شارك في المظاهره عدد من السياسيين
والبرلمانيين الفرنسيين خصوصا من اليسار
الفرنسيه
من جانب قال وزير العدل الفرنسيه نا باريس
تدعم كل الاكراد في فرنسا والتحقيقات
مستمره من جهته قال قائد شرطه باريس ان
واحده و30 شرطيا اصيبوا جر مواجهات اليوم
[موسيقى]
في تنفيذ هجوم باريس قد اكد انه ارتكب
الاعتداء لدوافع عنصريه وفقنا كشف مصدر
مقرب من التحقيقات وقال المصدر ان الشرطه
عثرت بحوزه المشتبه به على حقيبه صغيره
تضم مخزنين او ثلاثه ممتلئه بطلاقه الرصاص
وعند الطلقات من عيار 45 بداخلها 25 طلقه
على الاقل من جانبه قال المجلس الديمقراطي
الكردي انه من غير المقبول عدم وصف الهجوم
بالارهابي مرجيحا وجود دوافع سياسي
وقد نشرت وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه صورا
التقطت من كاميرات المراقبه تظهر لحظه
دخول المنفذ صالون حلاقه واطلاقه النهار
داخل المكان ما ادى الى مقتل شخص وجرح
اخرين في حين قتل المهاجم اثنين اخرين في
مكان قريب
هذا وقال وزير العدل الفرنسيه
ان فرنسا في حداد في عقاب الهجوم الذي
استهدف الدائره العاشره في باريس واسفر عن
مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من الجاليه الكرديه
في تصريحات صحفيه انه حريص على لقاء
ممثلين عن الجاليه الكرديه ليؤكد لهم
الدعم الكامل ورده على الجدل بشان توصيف
الجريمه بانها ارهابيه قال موريتيه ان
هناك فرقا بين الجريمه العنصريه والجريمه
الارهابيه يتمثلوا في شرط الانتماء الى
ايديولوجيا سياسيه يتم تبنيها حتى تصنف
الجريمه بانها ارهابيه حسب تعبير
انا من باريس مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي
نبدا معك محمد بالحديث عن اخر التطورات
المواجهات عما اسفلت والجدل ايضا اييه
الدائر
بشان توظيف ما حدث بالامس
اما المظاهرات
10 شخصا من الذين شاركوا في المواجهات
هؤلاء تم اعتقالهم وفقا لمحافظ باريس
ويخضعون للتحقيق ووصفه بانهم متطرفين
وحسب لنفس التصريحات فان اعتقالهم جاء على
خلفيه قيامهم بالاضرار منهم ممتلكات
العامه هذه التظاهر التي تحولت الى
مواجهات ادت كما ذكرتهم الى جرح واحد 31
شرطيا
بجروح خفيفه ايضا ثم الاضرار بعدم من
الممتلكات من بينها عدد منها السيارات ومن
الواجهات الزجاجيه وعلى كل حال هذه
المشاهد التي تتكرر في باريس عند كل
مظاهره من هذا الحجم هذا على مستوى هنا ما
حدث في ساحه الجمهوريه على مستوى التحقيق
مستمر
ويقينا الان لدى المحققين بان السبب عنصري
لا شك في ذلك بعد ان يعترف الفاعل بذلك
وبعد ايضا النتائج
المداهمه بيته حيث وجد فيه ما يدل على ان
هذا الفاعل كان يخطط لهذا الامر هذا
بالاضافه الى تاريخه الشخصي بحيث انه سبق
ان اعتقل العمل الماضي بسبب هجوم عنصر على
همم مخيم اللاجئين جرح فيه شخصين وايضا
مره ثانيه وثالثه وكل مره كانت الدوافع
العنصريه هي التي تحركها وهذا ما طرح
السؤال الان بشكل كبير في ما يتعلق اطلاق
سراحه لانه اطلق صراحه قبل 11 يوم فقط
وبالكاد عندما خرج من السجن نفذ هذه
العمليه التي هي الاكبر والاشنا والتي
خلفت اكبر عدد من الضحايا من بين كل
الجرائم التي قام بها طبعا كل هذا يطرح
سؤال ونقاش بشان توصيف هذه العمليه هذه
العمليه تقود السرطان الفرنسيه انها عمليه
او جريمه عنصريه ولكن لا احد وصفها بانها
جريمه ارهابيه وهذا ما دفع اولا الجاريه
الكرديه الى طرح سؤال ماذا يجب ان يتوفر
في هذه الجريمه حتى توصف بالارهابيه لان
حتى القانون الجنائي الفرنسي في مادته
421 واحد ونصف على انه اذا توفرت شرط
الرغبه في الاخلال بالامن العام عن طريق
التخويف من طرف فرد او جماعه فهذا يعني ان
العمليه يمكن ان يتوفر فيها شرطه الارهاب
وان توصف بانها ارهابيه
المحامون الذين يدافعون عن المركز الثقافي
الكردي وايضا عدد بناء السياسيين قالوا ان
النص القانوني الجنائي الفرنسي ينطبق على
هذه الجريمه التي توصف بان جريمه ارهابيه
لان الهدف منها هو التخويف همم
والفاعل والمجرم يعترف بانه الهدف من ذلك
عنصري ثم انه الايديولوجيه تقف وراء ذلك
على كل حال بالنسبه للمحامين نسبه عدد من
السياسيين لا يفهمون كيف لم يتم توصيف هذه
الجريمه بانه ارهابيه وهناك من يذهب ويقول
ان ربما يهلك هل يجب هل هناك رغبه سياسيه
في حصر وفي احتكار الارهاب للمسلمين اي
انه عندما يتعلق الامر بفاعل مسلم ف بشكل
مباشر يتم استخراج مصطلح الارهاب بينما
اذا تعلق الامر بشخص ليس مسلما فلحظتها
يكون نقاش اخر وهذا الامر يثير كما ذكرت
كثير من القلق لدى صفوف الجاليه الكرديه
وايضا لدى كثيرين من السياسيين شكرا من
الحقوقين محمد البقالي كنت معنا من باريس